say I do want to get to this Anderson
Cooper Melania Trump interview this
interview was embarrassing not for
Anderson Cooper uh and not even that
much for Melania Trump I think that this
interview was actually embarrassing for
Donald Trump and I'll explain why in a
second Melania Trump agreed to be
interviewed by CNN's Anderson Cooper and
this was the first interview since the
first uh sexual assault allegations came
out so we had this statement from
Melania Trump after the Billy Bush
recording and she said something about
you know it's inappropriate but I've
accepted Donald's apology and so should
everybody else basically and of course
that's ridiculous because nobody is
accepting the fact that Hillary Clinton
has agreed to be with Bill Clinton after
all of his alleged improprieties people
saying actually we should still attack
Hillary Clinton for that but Melania
Trump says hey I forgave him for this
and everybody supposed to to just fall
in line okay that that hypocrisy aside
so Melania Trump does this interview
with Anderson Cooper and her explanation
for what happened right remember that
remember the scenario Billy Bush and
Donald Trump or riding around in this
tour bus or they may have been parked
okay I don't want to miss speak and
Donald Trump just starts talking very
offhandedly about he does what he wants
to women sometimes you just gotta grab
women by the genitals and when you're
famous they let you do it and it's just
all fantastic and he loved it all and
Melania Trump's argument is Billy Bush
is really the one who is to blame there
it's not Trump Trump was tricked by
Billy Bush and encouraged by Billy Bush
say all those things if it weren't for
Billy Bush being there this interview
would lead you to believe when asked to
comment about women's attracted
attractiveness Trump would would have
said you know I really like to focus on
what's uh not at the skin level but
below I focus on what's inside women
that's it I I forget about all that
ranking women from one to ten anyway
that is obviously not the truth let's
play the clip of Melania Trump
explaining what happened on that tour
bus with Billy Bush it was ten days ago
that Access Hollywood release that tape
I'm wondering when you first saw it when
he first heard it what did you think
I I said to my husband that you know the
language is unappropriate it's not
acceptable and I was surprised because
that is not demanded I know and as you
can see from the tape the cameras were
not on it was only a mic and I wonder if
they even knew that the mic was on
because they were kind of a boy talk and
he was lead on like egg on from the host
to say dirty and bad stuff you feel the
host Billy Bush was sort of egging him
on yes yes is that language you had
heard him used before no no that's why I
was surprised because I said like I
don't know that person yeah what's less
believable hear that Milania never heard
Trump talking this way before or that
she actually believes that Trump was
egged on into saying the stuff I let's
break it down piece by piece number one
it's either a comically absurd lie that
Melania Trump never heard Trump speak in
this way before or it's true because
Trump reserved talk like that for like
the other 10 or 15 women that have come
forward and somehow Melania Trump was
exempt from hearing that type of
nonsense I don't know and then she says
this was boy talk again everybody says
Trump was a different person when this
happened acting like it's a 15 year old
kid with some kind of juvenile
indiscretion Trump was a 59 year old man
at this time right I it what boy talk
because this was a long time a time ago
where there are many grandparents who
were 59 years old and we're saying well
listen I mean he was this was a
different Donald Trump here and it was a
long time ago everything was different
but there is something here and this is
really why I find this this I don't know
if Melania Trump came up with these
lines on her own or if
maybe they were worked on together with
a team of people love to be a fly on the
room during that discussion if this is
what came out of it but that's a
different story if it's true that Donald
Trump was egged on by Billy Bush into
saying things that are according to
Milania remember things he's never said
before and doesn't use this type of
vocabulary and language if that's true
how can this guy handle being president
right i mean if you go if some random TV
host gets you to say things that you
have never said before in your life if
we're to believe Milania uh you get
pushed around you're a pushover and how
on earth is Trump going to be able to
withstand conversations with Vladimir
Putin how is he going to be able to deal
with the UN how is Trump going to be
able to go in and be in those situations
that we know President Obama has been in
many many times if like a 14 year old
boy he's just hope that this is the
opposite of how I talk but Billy Bush
clearly wants me to say something about
women so what the hell I'll talk about
sometimes you've got to grab them by the
genitals this is really embarrassing for
Trump if it's true and last thought on
this Billy Bush got fired right the guy
who said the really offensive stuff is
Trump and he's running for president and
Billy Bush no longer has a job because
he was involved in this relatively
casual conversation with Donald Trump
that's really the insanity it only makes
sense in a world where you believe
Melania story which is hey it was all
Billy bush's fault up without knowing it
Melania Trump has exposed trumpet as
being totally spineless and susceptible
to peer pressure if her claims are even
true and obviously we both know that
we're never going to find out send me
your thoughts on this i'm on twitter at
d pakman we'll take a break and be back
after this gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can
buy them for a low use price there's
never any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s